vous avez l'intention d'organiser des
voyages de groupe pour que les femmes
françaises puissent aller se faire
avorter à l'étranger on est un peu loin
du du concept vous confondez avec ivg ou
c d e régis les enterrements de vie de
garçon du moins dans le voilà plus de
bébés il se reconnaît plus dans le ton
va faire des bébés
je vais être clair avec vous pour 400
euros
vous allez vous la coller comme des
malades à budapest
qu'est-ce qui fait kiffer les gars
[Musique]
poursuivre par des chiens
la seule chose qu'on lui demande
c'est d'avoir un passeport en cours de
validité talent et c'est tout bon
combien de ventes aujourd'hui les gars
12 12 super tu as fait combien toile 3 3
vous allez élire et tu te casses
cette épaisse comme des clochards de
chez castel je me fais chier moi je n'en
peux plus d'accord on en est où 10 ans
plus tard c'est koi no job c'est de la
merde est en train de me dire on va
monter une boîte qui organise des
internautes it garçons en hongrie oui
parce qu'on n'est pas rentrée chez
castel exacto touche pas attaquer les
gens
van den putte elle a été pendant deux
ans un genre mauss à gros soucis
j'espère c'est qu'à la police au
quartier la choriste
[Musique]